in my earlier video I have talked about
gal for us system in Drosophila and how
it works and with this system with
utilizing the system how we can actually
over express or knock down a particular
team of our interest in this particular
video I would be focusing more on the
genetics what genetic crosses we can
perform to knock down but before
beginning just to refresher we have a
driver line one hand and we another
another side we have our respondent line
and what happens this tribal line is
actually a gal for line so it has a gal
for in the driver line gal fir is
actually placed under our tissue
specific promoter in order to get a
special control and in the respondent
line the particular gene of the RNA I
construct or the overexpression
construct for the particular gene is
actually placed in the chromosome of
these respondent line under our us
control so now we would look the genetic
crosses behind it so let's go into a new
space and let's look about genetics so
for instance if we write the tribal line
and let's say we want to knock down in
the neurons so we need a neuronal gal
for driver and in our case I have
earlier discussed that our neuronal
driver could be enough
II love gal phone so let's take the
example of a LOF gal for it's in love
see one five five over in the sea one
five five in the first chromosome and
other chromosomes there is no
manipulation so here we take this thing
the virgin female of this driver line
another side we have to take the
responder line the respondent line in
the respondent line we have the
particular
construct for RNA I of the particular
gene we want to log down so we have
let's say the particular RNA I construct
is in the third chromosome and it's
under US control so we would write us
gene a RNA I over us gene a RNA I so
this is our responder so now we would
cross the between these two we will take
the females from driver line we would
take some males from the respondent line
we can do the reverse also but for
instance so here we have taken the male
from the respondent line it's a Y
chromosome so we have taken the males
from the respondent line we have taken
the females virgin females from the
driver line now we crossed between the
two now we expect the f1 generation in
f1 generation we would expect long term
would happen so what we would do we
would write the f1 configuration genetic
configuration so it would be in love
c15 v / + / y or / + then second
chromosome there is no change in the
third chromosome we would get chin a RNA
i / + so actually he laughs / y or allow
/ thus there are true probabilities as
in the second chromosome they are both
normal so the second chromosome would be
normal and in 3rd chromosome here is
plus and in both cases this u.s. gene a
/ r nai and u.s. gene over r ni so only
possibility is us gene RNA i / + so what
happened in it is the particular
configuration of our f1 male and we said
that in this f1 mill the knockdown
happened so what actually happened here
we have in love over c1 1 5 in one
particular chromosome so this enough or
c1 1 v actually would produce
the gal for the gal for transcription
factor and this gal for transcription
factor is able to bind to the up in
upstream activation sequence us of these
particular RNA I construct and after
binding that it can express this
particular RNA I construct and
ultimately from here we would get the
so-called knockdown construct the TS RNA
which in turn would be cleaved by Donald
icer and would be processed and would
create the RNA I induced silencing
complex one thing we should remember
that here the driver line have the gal
form but the driver line doesn't have
the RNA i construct and respondent line
don't have the gal for but half the RNA
i construct so in driver lines talk or
in the respondent lines talk we won't
get a knock down of the particular gene
here gene a but when we combine these
two by crossing them in one particular
fly we have both gal for and both RNA i
that is why knockdown would be happening
in the f1 flight now question comes
where the knockdown would be happening
and how the tissue-specific knockdown
would be happening earlier i have
mentioned that a LOF c1 5 5 is a neuron
specific driver
so in lab c15 five would be expressed
only in the neurons of this particular
fly and us gene a RNA i this construct
would be present in all over the body of
that particular fly but in every cell
this particular construct won't get the
necessary gal for to drive its
expression only the tissue where the
expression of this particular RNA I
construct could be driven is the neurons
that is why this particular RNA I
construct would be only expressed in the
neuronal tissues and this particular
gene a the protein corresponding to gene
a would be knocked down only in the
neural tissues not elsewhere in the body
this is how the Cal 4 and
u.s. system is very accurate and by it
we can use actually tissue-specific
knockdown hope you enjoyed the video if
you liked my video please give it a
quick thumbs up share and please
subscribe and don't forget to leave
comments thank you